all praise belongs to Allah and we send
peace and salutations to Pro Muhammad
sahu alai wasallam alhamdulillah we have
our brother here Dante may Allah
preserve him and bless him as many of
you know that he embraced Islam
alhamdulillah and he's a Muslim and I
just wanted to talk about something
that's very important and beneficial the
attribute that he chose the name that he
chose as a Muslim is
ABD and it means the servant of the one
from the names of Allah the names of God
is Al the
one and that's a beautiful
name
ABD that's a beautiful
name why is it such a beautiful
name because we have in the Quran yes no
doubt Al is a name of God the one the
servant of the
one Allah said in the
Quran say he is Allah he is
one he is one in his lordship he is one
in his beautiful names and his perfect
attributes he is one in his right to be
worshiped alone he is one God is one and
that's the beauty of at Islam we believe
in one God we worship one
God
the Lord of all of the prophets and The
Messengers The Lord of Adam
Abraham Moses Jesus Muhammad every
Prophet The Lord of all of the creation
the lord of the heavens and the Earth
and we worship him
alone say he is Allah the one he is
one and look at that Subhan
Allah Allah T blessing us to be Muslims
blessing our brothers to embrace Islam
Islam it teaches us to be the best
version of who we
are to try and complete ourselves
because as Muslims we want to complete
ourselves yes but
also we have to help those who are
around us Mah the brother he invested in
the area that he's from we see that
that's something that we're trying to do
also in Philadelphia why to help others
that are around us and
yes it is necessary that one that we
have a correct state of heart our heart
is correct it's healthy likewise our
mind how do we keep our mind healthy as
Muslims who can tell me why eating
healthy food yes okay what
else no what else though how do we keep
our help my our minds healthy we can do
what every yes what else though what do
we stay away from ch
no what else the evil what else no what
else no doubt 100% but what else no what
else for your mind something that is
going to affect your mind no what else
drugs drugs alcohol why because we need
our heart yes we purify the heart from
any false
belief any corrupt yes that's with the
statement purify the heart also we
purify our mind we keep our mind right
also our
bodies n our souls why because we want
to be the best version of who we are but
also we want to help those who are
around us and all of us our brother
here ra even you as the Youth of the
community you all have a role you guys
are the future of
tomorrow you guys are going to be the
teachers you're going to be the leaders
of tomorrow you're going to be whether
it's in sports whatever you choose in
life you're going going to be the future
of tomorrow but in order to be the
leaders that you can be you have to be
prepared for it and Islam blesses us
Islam allows us to do
that so that's why I wanted to talk
about the name that the brother he
chose ABD the servant of the one
because God is in control of everything
and now look the places our communities
they need us no doubt in order for us to
help our communities we need to be right
we need to be correct but our
communities need us the young people
they need us n even the old people they
need
us but we have to be prepared for the
job it's like the brother he boxes when
he goes into that ring he trains he
trains trains hard physically I mean I I
train hard in my house you train hard
yet your father told me that you like
Saka that's your son right that's your
son there you like Saker as well no
that's justay no but we
look but my point is this a person
trains now because they're prepared for
something do you know we prepare as well
all of this when we pray we're training
no doubt I mean it's the relationship
between us and Allah but and we're
fulfilling the obligation of Allah but
also it's training the soul and you're
preparing for the task that is out there
because it's not easy it's not easy we
need to be have strong hearts n we need
to have our mind sharp we need to have
our bodies no doubt fit because there's
a responsibility out there and I'm
telling you if you prepare right you can
change the world all of you you can
change the world even though you are
young you have a role in a
responsibility all of you and we all
have roles and responsibilities and
we're all important now every single one
of us regardless of what we're doing the
person as I said who cleans the Masjid
is important the one who washes the
windows is important the one who Le the
prayer the one who teaches the classes
all of us have a role we're all
important we're all Brothers we're all
important every single one of us have a
role and that's alhamdulillah you know
something that we have to recognize and
understand that many people for the
Youth many people famous people are
embracing Islam many people interested
in Islam D my dad ask me for help and I
helping masah excellent look at how many
people Subhan Allah just the brother who
embraced in Saudi the boxer what was
name n huh big baby big baby he just
recently embraced prior to we know
alhamdulillah Tyson was Muslim before
them Muhammad Ali how many people
successful famous people embracing Islam
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he said a beautiful thing right he
said the best of those before they in
the times of ignorance meaning before
they became Muslim they will be the best
in Islam meaning when if they gain
knowledge and understanding of the
religion meaning you take anything that
equality that you had you take and you
improve it you take it to a Next Level
and Islam allows you to do that to be
the best of what you're doing you want
to be a teacher you be the best teacher
you want to for example you want to do
whatever you want to do you be the best
in that Islam equips us for that you
know and no doubt there's no success
success except with the aid in the
assistance of God Allah because Allah
means what the one who deserves to be
woried Allah in Arabic God in English
believe in one God worship that one God
and trying to try to live our life the
best way we can and we're not going to
be perfect we all try to the best of our
ability aldah look he took time out to
come and visit you guys why because he
knows as the youth you're
important he's busy he has things to do
how many people famous people have come
and visited you do you know I mean
alhamdulillah he's famous for us M you
what's his
name yeah for you guys alhamdulillah but
how many people outside there you took
his time out to come and visit you
alhamdulillah as you know as your
brother you know alhamdulillah because
again same way he's doing work in the
community and there's more work for him
and there's more work for me and you
know Raha and everybody else there's
work for us to you know to to be done he
understands the importance of you know
the youth and giving you opportunities
whether it's education whe IT jobs now
and also helping protect you from the
things that maybe some of the brothers
they went through what did I tell you
earlier who can remind me the wise
person is who I told you earlier only if
you know who's the wise person I told
you before they came the wise person is
someone who learns from other people's
mistak the wise person is someone who
learns from other people's mistakes my
father told me
that Mr Abdi right and it's true he said
the fool is the one who learns from his
own mistakes if I made a mistake in life
I'm going to say don't make that mistake
he made a mistake in life he's going to
say don't make that mistake if talik
made a mistake he's going to say don't
make that mistake Charlie Isa you know
ra Justin our brother Jal ABD we're
going to say don't make that mistake I
made that mistake I don't want you to
make it that's the wise person he's
going to say you know what I'm not going
to make that mistake the fool is the one
who's going to say you know what I hear
you but I just want to make that mistake
some mistakes you can't come back from
that's the issue somebody asked me that
and it was a deep question I was in
Chicago visiting Big D ABD and I went to
the you know the place where he does
youth work and he you know people who
have you know involved in for example
certain things trying to escape that
life and one somebody asked me that
question they said but um what about you
know the fool if he just says you know I
want to just experience it and I I it's
deep because that's the first time
anyone asked me that question I had to
try and think on my toes you know and I
said then some mistakes you can't come
back from you kill someone you go to
prison for life you you know you're in
prison for life or still exactly certain
mistakes you can't come back from or
somebody ends up you get in a car you
know somebody's going to maybe get
involved in something and there's guns
and you get in that car and somebody
shoots you and you end up dying you
can't come back once you're dead meaning
in this life some mistakes you cannot
come back from yes there are mistakes
when we make them alhamdulillah we're
still living
God is all forgiving we can all be
better and we all make mistakes all of
us you know it doesn't matter who we are
we all make mistakes and that's the
beauty of Islam when we worship God we
worship god with love love of him and
that keeps us going in our worship of
him at the same time hope meaning that
if we make a mistake we repent to him
and also fear because we know that he
may punish us for certain things that we
do that are wrong that's the beauty of
this religion this religion is beautiful
and that's why when our Prophet came
with it it didn't just change
some individuals it helped change the
world and Islam Subhan Allah the beauty
of it how many people from different
walks of life accepted it black white
Arab non-arab even slaves accepted it
because they said this is the truth
there was an individual one of the best
Muslims it was an Abyssinian slave he
was a slave and when Prophet Muhammad
look Prophet muhammmad didn't think that
he didn't look down upon people and say
you know because you know I was chosen
no Prophet Muhammad when you righteous
and righteous right Pious people they
never look down on people they just say
you know I'm striving to be righteous
and I want to help you know my people
around me I want them to be upon what is
good we don't think we're better than
anyone no righteous person think thinks
like that Prophet Muhammad he even gave
he invited even the slaves to Islam and
one of them accepted Islam what was his
name who could tell me who was the
Abyssinian slave that accepted Islam in
Mecca B because he accepted is Islam the
Pagan Arabs they used used to drag him
in the streets to try and punish him
because they didn't want him to be a
Muslim and he look he had the courage
that's why I say he said something it
relates to the name which is a and it
just came to me I didn't think about
this earlier when they were dragging B
through the streets right dragging him
and they would make him bake in the hot
sun trying to punish him to force him to
leave the religion he would
say God is one God is one look at that
that's why I said earlier and there I
said when you have the correct belief
right you don't fear no man and Pain No
Doubt all of us have a level a threshold
of pain that we we may crack but still
at the same time look at B he showed us
making him in you know in armor they
would put armor on him and bake him in
the Sun and he would
say God is one God is one and he
wouldn't leave the religion Prophet
Muhammad said about him that he's from
the people of paradise
Allah look at that look how Allah raised
him he was from a slave he became one of
our
leaders that's why Omar said that you
know he said Abu Bakr is our leader and
he freed one of our leaders meaning bah
because one of the Muslims Abu Bakr he
saw B being tortured and he said I'm
going to free you and they said you know
they wanted x amount of money more than
it was he said money don't matter cuz
that's my brother and that's what I'm
saying money comes and goes true
Brotherhood and friendship you can't buy
it
you know at the end of the day money
comes and goes but true Brotherhood you
can't buy it that's why Allah said in
the Quran to the prophet he said if you
spent everything in the earth you would
not be able to join their hearts but
Allah joined their hearts through that
statement none has the right to be
worshiped truth except Allah we have an
um we have a Brotherhood all over this
world like I said Subhan Allah brother's
reaching out to me asking about the
brother he doesn't know them you know in
the emirats in Saudi Arabia in the UK
and these are people some of them
alhamdulillah some of them in the same
you know field as the brother and you
know involved in you know some of them
doing other things business people
regular people we're in um imagine that
imagine all of us go to our communities
and we have that level you know that
cooperation and that Bond what we can
achieve in our communi we don't wait for
government grants we' be out there
without like I said one of the things
aldah we're trying to do in Philadelphia
even without you know you know our own
you know means alhamdulillah and you
know and the skills that we have in
changing our communities listen
I said to him earlier some people want
to control us they can't control a man
that says you know my Lord is Allah
because that is our Lord we don't
worship any man right and the person
that can't be controlled like that you
know no doubt alhamdulillah we obey the
laws of God and we're not people who are
chaotic and you alhamdulillah we're
organized and stuff like that and we
have we conduct ourselves properly but
imagine what we can achieve with that
level of cooperation in the inner cities
if everyone with for example whether
they had money or just a skill and we
came back and we gave to the community
like he's coming back and visiting you
guys imagine what we could
achieve imagine what we can achieve and
that's why the brothers who may listen
to this later on who have wealth or have
Fame you're wasting your
lives the devil has this trick that you
know you know you know being in places
where you shouldn't be and spending
those making it rain and all those type
of things and I know the youth they
don't know what I'm referring to and
that's a good thing that's a Shan they
got you know one of our you know
somebody you know for example they got
buying things that are not really going
to benefit us in any way shape or form
but we could change our communities if
we take a portion of that back and we
all for example gave back and even if
you don't have money you got a skill you
went to University you went back to the
community and you taught and you Ted the
children everyone has a role I was
telling the brothers they have skills
mallah for example with some of the
technology we all have a role everyone
every single one of us just the fact
that a person says my name is ABD and we
heard B say that's a powerful message
you know that's saying
listen Allah is the greatest you know I
worship that one God you know and again
that doesn't mean any of us are perfect
I'm sitting before you and I'm talking
to you I'm not perfect what I say is a
reminder for me as well I'm not saying
it just you know for you I say it for
myself I need reminders you know every
all of us need reminders we're all
Brothers at the end of the day that's
why and I'll close with this I don't
want to go on too long there's a small
Surah in the Quran if we just understood
it right IM sha said about one of the
scholars of Islam he said if if people
understood it it would be sufficient for
them what Surah is that can any of you
tell
me Subhan Allah how old are you wow
Allah yes Allah said by
time all of mankind is in a state of
loss everyone is in loss look the rich
man the poor man black man white man the
king the one who's just a regular
citizen Allah said everyone is in loss
everybody but then he said
except except those who believe they
have correct belief they believe in one
God they worship that one God they have
the correct belief
look and they do righteous Deeds they
try they try their best to do righteous
Deeds right so look that's those people
they try and complete themselves yeah I
want to try and be the best version of
me but they're not selfish with it cuz
you all we all have a role they're not
selfish with it they don't say you know
I'm doing well I'm not worrying about no
they then Allah said he
mentioned so in addition to them trying
to be the best version of
them Allah said and they advise one
another with truth so they go out into
the community and they they advise
people with truth what's going to
benefit them and they advise one another
to be
patient look completing ourselves
complete helping our
communities I believe hamdah to be
honest with you the things I'm seeing
and the people alhamdulillah around us I
believe change is coming for in the
cities may Allah you know grant us all
success and may Allah guide all of the
people now that's all I want to say
alhamdulillah I don't want to say
anything else you have anything that you
want to say anything anybody
alhamdulillah beautiful this is
beautiful historical alhamdulillah Allah
bless you you know alhamdulillah again
you guys are important you know when you
go home you look you say I'm important
when you see the brother you say I met
him alhamdulillah that's my brother you
know know alhamdulillah if you need help
from any of us you say that's my
teacher you know that's our brother you
know aldah and Charlie and you know Jal
Justin and Sab and ABD and Isa and
everyone
else
andad and
abdd you know abdim's 16 right he told
me earlier he told me a story he said he
helped chter some of the children he's
going to help insh tal he's going to
help chter I told him I said to him
earlier I said he graduated from the
school here he was like he wants to
study abroad but he said while while
he's here he has some time I said you
have to give back one you have to try
and get you're learning Islam amongst in
the Masid but you have to go on and get
some skills whether it's college or
whatever and also you have to give back
true to these brothers education wise we
want them sharp religious we want them
sharp physically we want them sharp we
want them sharp in every way that they
can why because you guys are the leaders
of tomorrow but you're only going to be
able to fulfill the role if you are
nurtured and educated correctly we're
not going to get that from Instagram
it's not about the Grim people be
fronting all the time on the gr if you
just want life to be the gram no people
on the gram you go you see them in real
life You' be like wow he was pretending
no yes if it gets on Instagram we're not
saying but we want you to do in real
life cuz there's things that need to be
done that's what we want from the youth
that alhamd you have change yes real
change and if it makes it to social
media alhamdulillah that's just the
means and a tool but we want real life
to agree with what's going on there
because sometimes social media Instagram
is like Hollywood for some people you
know not trying to prolong it but
since some of Youth there boys and girls
are influenced by some of the things
they're seeing on social media Tik Tok
and Instagram and they're doing these
dances and singing these songs and
things that they're hearing on social
media can you just maybe give them a
word of advice about leaving these
things off yeah be influenced in the
best way be influenced by good be
influenced by positive things
something's going to benefit your your
your soul your mind you is your
character your children your families
your brothers stuff that's benefit it's
going to last you know have take good
one of the ways that you you know you do
good you have good Role Models name for
me a good role model yeah I'll give it
to you back name for me a good role
model who's a good role model for you
who do you look who do you think he's a
good brother I want to be like
him my dad your dad exactly that's why I
tell brothers and children that all the
time you know your own mother is is your
father that gets up to go to work and he
comes home and he helps you know he
provides for the household you know that
that's a that's that's where you should
look at a role model as well yes no
doubt what
else give me m Prophet muhammmad
wasallam yes the prophets and the the
best examples Allah said about Prophet
Muhammad specifically you have the best
example who
else H Somali is
M you know you know alhamdulillah you
have many Role Models yes alhamdulillah
the brother look he embraced Islam
that's that that like I said that
doesn't mean any of us when you you say
in hassali we're not perfect again may
Allah forgive us for our sins the
prophet taught us a supplication Prophet
Muhammad taught us
for us to say oh Allah I rung my soul
greatly no one forgives sins except for
you forgive me with a forgiveness from
yourself and have mercy upon me you God
are all forgiving most merciful Subhan
Allah Prophet Muhammad taught us to say
that that's deep at the end of the day
we have shortcomings but again yes
alhamdulillah we have many Role Models
good Role Models yes you see somebody
alhamdulillah they they role modeling
good and you have like I said so many
small things none of you should look
down upon good none of you like small
things and I was saying to the brothers
before you may do something small and
the reward is great it might just be a
word that you say to somebody and that
benefits that person their whole life
and they remember it or just the fact
that you just
prayed growing up Subhan Allah Prince
Nim I used to see him you know I've seen
him live as well I heard him say you
know Allah is the greatest and be like
subh Allah he's look he's saying the
greatest he's
saying even in the Walk of Life that
he's in no doubt in our role mods the
prophets The Messengers the scholars of
Islam the righteous and so on and so
forth but small things we never look
down upon them everyone has a role
everyone has a r all right remember
that we'll stop there
inshallah